dans les quatre dernières années surtout
les emplois qui ont été créés à travers
le canada on représente 22% de la
population canadienne un peu plus et je
16 % des emplois qui ont été créés ici
chez nous ça c'est inquiétant est ce que
dominique anglade en raison de dire que
la création d'emplois au québec a été
plus faible que son poids démographique
pendant le mandat du gouvernement le
goût
oui c'est vrai
depuis octobre 2018 près de 880 seize
mille emplois ont été créés au canada
dont 156 mails au québec ça représente
17 % des emplois au pays alors que la
province compte pour 23% de la
population
est ce que le bilan était meilleur
gouvernement libéral précédent oui 2000
2014 à septembre 2018 225 mille emplois
ont été créés dans la province ces 22 %
du total canadien par contre il faut pas
oublier que le gouvernement legault a dû
composer avec la pandémie qui a entraîné
des fermetures et de nombreuses mises à
pied car la cac est arrivé au pouvoir le
taux de chômage était de 5,3 pour ça il
est maintenant de 4,5 pour ça le plus
faible au pays
[Musique]
avec le vieillissement de la population
et les départs massifs à la retraite le
marché du travail se resserre en juin on
comptait plus de 270 mille postes
vacants au québec c'est davantage que le
nombre total de chômeurs la pénurie de
main d'oeuvre s'est aggravée dans les
dernières années depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir du gouvernement legault le taux
de postes vacants a plus que doublé il
est passé de 3,2 à 6,7 pour cent il est
plus élevé dans une seule autres
provinces la colombie-britannique